Vamos directo al grano con este análisis, porque hoy desplosamos uno de los cambios
regulatorios más gigantescos a los que se ha enfrentado el ecosistema sanitario en Chile.
Para quienes administran hospitales, centros clínicos, laboratorios o plataformas de telemedicina,
hay una fecha que debería estar marcada en rojo en todos los calendarios estratégicos,
el 1 de diciembre de 2026. Ese día entran en pleno vigor dos marcos legales que van a
transformar radicalmente cómo procesamos, resguardamos y auditamos la información clínica.
Y ojo, no hablamos de actualizar unos simples términos y condiciones. Hablamos de un rediseño
absoluto de la infraestructura digital en el sector salud. 20.000 unidades tributarias
mensuales. Es una barbaridad. Estamos hablando de unos 1.400 millones de pesos chilenos como
sanción económica máxima por infracciones gravísimas bajo la nueva normativa. Para poner
esto en perspectiva, el coste de una sola de estas multas equivale básicamente a comprar un
equipo de resonancia magnética de última generación. El cuide la cuestión es entender
lo que esto significa.
Una brecha de datos ya no es un pequeño dolor de cabeza para el equipo de soporte técnico. Es un
riesgo clínico y financiero de primerísimo nivel, capaz de comprometer seriamente la viabilidad y la
reputación de cualquier institución médica. Nuestra hoja de ruta para este análisis incluye
cinco puntos muy claros. Primero, las leyes 21.719 y 21.663. Segundo, el tratamiento de
las fichas clínicas como datos sensibles. Tercero, la obligatoriedad de la IPD. Cuarto,
las leyes 21.719 y 21.663. Y lo que supone este gran cambio regulatorio. Durante décadas,
el sector ha operado en una especie de zona gris tecnológica, sin fiscalizadores demasiado
estrictos. Pues bien, eso se acabó. Hoy el ecosistema es dual. Por un lado,
tenemos la reciente ley 21.663 de ciberseguridad, que da un poder enorme a la nueva Agencia
Nacional de Ciberseguridad y a su equipo de la expuesta, el CISIRT. Y en paralelo,
entra en juego la ley 21.719 sobre protección de datos personales, que crea la APDP, la Agencia
de Protección de Datos Personales. En la práctica, esto significa que las áreas de tecnología de
las clínicas tienen que estructurarse para rendir cuentas ante dos organismos muy poderosos y con
facultades sancionatorias reales al mismo tiempo. Es un auténtico malabarismo operativo.
Pasamos a la sección 2, fichas clínicas consideradas como datos sensibles y el impacto
de los datos de salud. Aquí entramos en el corazón del asunto. La ley es tajante al
definir la información sensible. Cualquier dato sobre estados de salud, información biométrica,
perfiles genéticos y, por descontado, los diagnósticos médicos, exige ahora protección
máxima. Tratar estos registros requiere un estándar excepcionalmente riguroso. Ya no nos
vale con un consentimiento tácito o con dejar una casilla premarcada en un formulario de admisión.
El consentimiento tiene que ser explícito, inequívoco y revocable. Y si lo pensamos bien,
tiene todo el sentido.
Un acceso indebido a datos médicos puede generar discriminación o exponer las vulnerabilidades
más íntimas de una persona. De esta legislación se extrae una premisa brutal. Esa vieja cultura
hospitalaria de guardemos todo por si acaso se ha convertido en una bomba de relojería. El
mandato actual es pura minimización y proporcionalidad. Las instituciones están obligadas a tener políticas
de retención activas. Es decir, una vez que el propósito original de un dato ha caducado y no
puede mantenerlo, esa información se elimina de forma sistemática o se anonimiza por completo. Es así de simple.
Avanzamos a la sección 3. La obligatoriedad de la EIPD y el mandato de diagnóstico.
Vamos a desglosar este concepto que es absolutamente clave. La evaluación de impacto en la protección de datos, o EIPD.
Y la palabra más importante de toda esta diapositiva es antes. No es el típico formulario burocrático que
rellenamos para salir del paso después de instalar un sistema. Si un centro médico va a lanzar un
nuevo portal para pacientes, a usar inteligencia artificial para diagnosticar o simplemente a
cambiar su base de datos principal, la ley exige que este análisis se haga de forma proactiva.
Hacerlo cuando el sistema ya está procesando datos sensibles significa que ese software ha nacido
siendo ilegal. Para que quede súper claro, pensemos en la EIPD exactamente como si fuera un proceso de
atención médica. El proceso de atención médica es un proceso de atención médica que se hace con la
EIPD. El paso 1 es el mapeo de datos, digamos que es la anamnesis del paciente. Consiste en saber con
total exactitud clínica qué datos se capturan, en qué servidor residen y a qué proveedores externos
van a parar. El paso 2 es identificar los riesgos, que sería el diagnóstico, qué pasaría si hay una
filtración en ese servidor. Y el paso 3 es la mitigación, la receta médica. Aquí se definen los
controles técnicos, como aislar servidores, y se documenta absolutamente todo para tener pruebas
del cumplimiento. Sección 4. Ciberseguridad y reporte de brechas. Hablemos de los protocolos
de seguridad operativa. Imaginemos que ocurre lo peor, un ciberataque masivo, como un ransomware,
que secuestra los datos del hospital. En ese momento de pánico, se activa un doble cronómetro
operativo que no perdona. La ley de ciberseguridad nos da una ventana increíblemente estrecha,
apenas tres horas para reportar el incidente al CSICERT. Y por otro lado, la ley de protección
de datos nos da un máximo de 72 horas para notificar la filtración a la APDP. Sin un
protocolo ensayado hasta el aburrimiento y altamente automatizado,
es literalmente imposible cumplir con estos tiempos mientras intentamos apagar el fuego
en los servidores. Todo esto demuestra que el cumplimiento ya no es solo cosa del departamento
legal. La privacidad tiene que incrustarse en el mismísimo código informático de la clínica.
Hablamos de medidas muy concretas. Cifrado absoluto en reposo, para cualquier tabla que
contenga diagnósticos o números de identificación. Hablamos de limpiar a fondo los registros del
sistema para que un simple log de errores no exponga el nombre de un paciente. Hablamos
de planes de respuesta documentados al milímetro.
Hablamos, por supuesto, de desarrollar portales donde la gente pueda ejercer sus derechos ARS-OB,
acceso, rectificación, supresión, oposición y portabilidad, y que el sistema informático ejecute
esas órdenes de forma automática y fiable. Finalmente, llegamos a la sección 5, la ruta
de cumplimiento clínico y el camino hacia la resiliencia. Esta lista es, esencialmente,
un plan de salud preventivo indispensable para nuestra infraestructura digital. Todo tiene que
empezar con un levantamiento integral, creando el famoso RAT, el registro de actividades de
tratamiento, que es el gran inventario de los flujos de datos. Le siguen políticas estrictas
sobre el BIOD, es decir, los dispositivos personales que los médicos utilizan en los
pasillos de la clínica. Dada la sensibilidad de estos datos, hay que nombrar sí o sí a un
delegado de protección de datos, un DPO, que garantice todo a nivel interno. Y, finalmente,
implementar el cifrado y ensayar los protocolos de incidentes a 3 y 72 horas de los que acabamos
de hablar. El tiempo pasa volando y la exigencia a estas nuevas agencias fiscalizadoras va a sentar
brutal en el país. Las instituciones que vean esto no como una carga administrativa,
sino como una oportunidad gigante para blindar la confianza de sus pacientes,
van a definir el estándar de oro en la medicina del futuro. Así que, la pregunta clave es,
¿sobreviviría la infraestructura actual a una auditoría estricta en 2026?
Es el momento de empezar esos mapeos de datos, hoy mismo.